let me uh ask you about the
this other world that of machine
learning of deep learning
uh what's your thoughts on the history
and the current progress of machine
learning field
that's often progressed sort of
separately
as a space of ideas and space of people
than the theoretical computer science or
just even computer science world
yeah it's really um very different from
the theoretical computer science world
because
yeah the results about it
algorithmic performance tend to be
empirical
it's more akin to the world of sat
solvers where we
observe that for formulas and arising in
practice see the solver does well
so it it's of that type it's where we're
moving into the
empirical evaluation of algorithms
now it's clear that they've been huge
successes in um
image processing robotics
uh natural language processing a little
less so but
across the spectrum of of uh
game playing is another one there have
been great successes
and one of those effects is that it's
not too hard to become a millionaire if
you can get a reputation in machine
learning and there'll be all
kinds of companies that will be willing
to offer you the moon because they
they think that if they have
ai at their disposal then they can solve
all kinds of problems
um but there are limitations
um um
one is that the solutions that you get
by
uh for from to uh
supervise learning problems uh through
convolutional neural networks
seem to perform amazingly well
even for inputs that are outside the
training set
[Music]
but we don't have any theoretical
understanding of why that's true
secondly the solutions the the networks
that you get
uh are very hard to understand and so
very little insight comes out
so yeah yeah they may seem to work on
your training set
and you may be able to discover
whether your photos occur in a
different sample of inputs or not
um but we don't really know what's going
on we don't know the
the features that distinguish the
photographs or the objects are
are not easy to characterize
well it's interesting because you
mentioned coming up with a small circuit
yeah to solve a particular size problem
yeah
it seems that neural networks are kind
of small circuits
in a way yeah uh but they're not
programs sort of like
the the things you've designed are
algorithms programs right
algorithms neural networks aren't able
to
develop algorithms to solve a problem
is it well they are more of a function
they are algorithms it's just
that they're uh but
sort of uh well yeah it's a it could be
a semantic question but
there's not a algorithmic style
manipulation
of the input perhaps you could argue
there is
yeah well it feels a lot more like a
function
of the input it's a yeah it's a function
it's a computable function
it's it's um once you have the network
you can
simulate it on a given input and figure
out the output
but what you you know if you're if
you're trying to recognize
images then you don't know what features
of the image are really
being uh
determinant of of what the circuit is
doing the circuit is
sort of a very intricate and
you know it's not clear that the the
you know the the simple characteristics
that you're looking for the
the edges of the objects or whatever
they may be
they're not emerging from the structure
of the circuit
well it's not clear to us humans but
it's clear to the circuit
yeah well right i mean uh
it's not clear to sort of the um
the elephant how the human brain works
but it's clear
to us humans we can explain to each
other our reasoning
and that's why the cognitive science the
psychology field exists
maybe maybe the whole thing of being
explainable to humans is a little bit
overrated
oh maybe yeah i guess i you know you
could say the same thing about our brain
that
when we perform acts of cognition we
have no idea how we do it really
sure we do though i mean we for
at least for the visual system the
auditory system and so on we do
get some understanding of the principles
that they operate under but
for many deeper cognitive tasks we don't
have that
that's right
you